[Music]
listen gun fans the harp has a very
unique sound that's very rich Nova turns
and incredibly beautiful somewhere
between the guitar and piano and it's so
pretty you so soft harpist on arava
travels the world with her harp playing
concerts
I started playing hop when I was eight I
don't think I used to practice much
there are people who can confirm that
harbour and a half ago Hertz
I mean if I heard a harp in a musical
daycare center in the city of benefit
and even just visually it's a magical
instrument for such a small girl so I
went home and said I want to start
playing hothouse and it worked it's half
wish for you
Brava is dedicated to music but also
tries to find balance in her life
through social activities taking a nice
walk or meeting friends whom you know
from outside of music because of course
I have a big circle of friends who are
musicians but not just them yeah and in
the evening I have to say okay works
over let's go and drink a beer now and
that's nice it's important otherwise you
turn weird cause I'm in scrubs
she also uses the breaks between
concerts to visit family in the western
part of Germany we're glad our daughter
has found something she likes to do
especially music because we play music
ourselves and know how good it feels
it's one step after the other you can't
say in advance how far it will go
[Music]
I didn't decide to do something
professionally with music until I was 17
it would have been a shame if I'd
already specialized earlier you have to
develop first and find out who you
really are before you can decide what to
do with the rest of your life at 28 this
harpist has a bright future ahead of her